eigentlich lernen wir ja dass die welt
natürlich ist alles was wir erleben die
wissenschaft chemie physik und so weiter
unterliegen naturgesetzen aber jetzt
scheint ein albtraum für alle physiker
und physikerinnen weltweit realität zu
werden egal wie verzweifelt sie auch
daran arbeiten die suche nach neuen
zeichen scheitert immer wieder auf ein
neues die physiker und physikerinnen
haben jetzt eine verblüffende erklärung
es gibt keine naturgesetze sondern alles
ist unnatürlich wie bitte wir leben in
einer quasi künstlichen welt jetzt
entwicklungszeiten fix und herzlich
willkommen
30 jahren hatten physiker die idee mit
dem large hadron collider lhc im
schweizerischen genf große sprünge in
der physik fachwelt zu machen ihre
vision der weltweit grösste
teilchenbeschleuniger sollte bei höheren
energien als je zuvor
die eigenschaften der natur noch genauer
untersuchen dabei sollte die entdeckung
neuer revolutionäre elementarteilchen
fast nur noch eine nebensache sein doch
pustekuchen
die ergebnisse des elexis sind bisher
mehr als ernüchternd zumindest auf den
ersten blick alle teilchen die bislang
im teilchenbeschleuniger entdeckt werden
konnten denn die fachwelt bereits aus
dem ich sage es mal profi provozierend
langweiligen wenngleich auch noch nicht
vollständigen standardmodell der
teilchenphysik die entdeckung des higgs
boson im jahr 2012 war lediglich das
letzte teilchen was noch fehlte um das
standardmodell zu vervollständigen
wichtige info das higgs boson ist das
teilchen dass der materie die masse gibt
doch das reicht nicht aus super
symmetrische teilchen neutral - zum
beispiel müssen dringend entdeckt werden
um die bislang aufgestellten gleichung
für vervollständigen und diese in ihrer
natürlichkeit abzurunden
die ergebnislose suche der physikerinnen
und physiker gleicht somit tatsächlich
einer geplatzten sensation so sichert
sich die forscherteams damals auf waren
teilchen der dunklen materie oder
geschwister der explosion zu finden um
so enttäuschter sind die jetzt
tatsächlich konnte keine einzige
voraussage die damals getroffen wurde
wie sehr experimentell bestätigt werden
egal wie fieberhaft auch gesucht wird es
herrscht katerstimmung unter den
physikern und physikerin weltweit das
was sich alle wünschen ist ein zumindest
mal ein kleiner hinweis auf eine neue
physik ein teilchen das nicht ins
standardmodell hinein park quasi etwas
das eine vollständigere theorie der
natur abliefert dabei gab es einige
große freundin momente zum beispiel noch
im dezember 2015 damals zeigte sich die
sogenannte die fotomodelle einen
überschuss an proton paaren in den daten
in mehr als 500 studien suchten sich die
theoretiker unter den physikern nach
ihrer erklärung denn sie vermuteten
dahinter die entdeckung eines neuen
rolle
zur näheren elementarteilchen und sahen
schon eine neue aufregende ära der
teilchenphysik auf sich zukommen heute
wissen die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler dass sie sich dabei wohl
nur um zufällige schwankungen gehandelt
haben muss was für ein cross manche
physikerinnen und physiker vor allem aus
dem theoretischen bereich wählen aber
auch diese diese ergebnisse als ein
aussagekräftiges ergebnis ihr fazit die
gesetze der natur seien eben doch nicht
so natürlich wie man es bisher
angenommen habe um die natürlichkeit der
physik plausibel erklären zu können
müsste man eine art supersymmetrie
nachweisen die theorie
dazu gibt es schon länger doch der
experimentellen beweis
wer wie den blieben uns die physiker
schuldig der theorie nach erhöhen
elementarteilchen der materie die quarks
oder elektronen die masse der
higgs-teilchen dazu müsste ein super
symmetrisches boson existieren das quasi
als überträger teilchen einer
wechselwirkung die hicks masse wiederum
verringert diese theorie der
supersymmetrie liefern im gegensatz zu
anderen erklärungsansätzen der
natürlichkeit einige vorteile und so
glaubte eine ganze physiker und
physikerinnen generation fest an wie
noch in keinem der großen
teilchenbeschleuniger der welt konnten
super symmetrische partner der teilchen
bislang nachgewiesen werden egal mit
welchen energien mannes auch versuchte
stellt euch mal vor den neunzigerjahren
knobel die fachwelt an diese aufgabe
durch die immer höhere beschleunigung
hat sich auch die kluft vergrößern
zwischen den hypothetischen super
partnern und den bereits bekannten
teilchen viele physikerinnen und
physiker glauben deswegen dass sich der
einfluss der teilchen und ihrer super
partner auch das higgs boson nicht
länger ausgleichen können da die
supersymmetrie stark gebrochen zwei
andere forscherteams vor allem aus dem
bereich der experimentalphysik haben den
letzten funken hoffnung noch nicht
verloren und weigern sich standhaft die
supersymmetrie jetzt aufzugeben die
modelle und varianten dieser theorie
sein so individuell dass sich teilchen
auf unerwartete weise verbergen könnten
die suche muss deswegen weitergehend
sagen wie und an einer höchst spannenden
datenlage dies noch zu analysieren die
fehler
dank sicher nicht das lager der
fünfziger und sicheren ist gespalten
die entdeckung bleiben aus und die krise
verschafft sich die theoretiker und
theoretikerin unter ihnen haben sich
mittlerweile damit abgefunden eine
weitere letzte möglichkeit ernsthaft in
betracht zu ziehen
demnach und da haltet euch fest sei die
masse der explosion einfach nicht
natürlich weiter gedacht würde dies
bedeuten dass viele verschiedene
universum mit ganz unterschiedlichen
kombis von falschen matten existieren
würden atome und somit auch lebewesen
könnten jedoch nur in solche universum
mit leichten explosionen entstehen eine
theorie die experimentell wohl niemals
zu belegen ist und somit zu der nächsten
kontroverse in der physik welt führt
denn demnach wäre das toll com beliebig
und in jedem universum an dass sie das
universum wer irgendwie künstlich zudem
beginnen die theoretischen physiker und
physikerinnen nun damit völlig neue
erklärungsansätze felix matthes gewinn
ganz unabhängig von neuen entdeckungen
die eventuell noch am elektroden könnten
ihrer ansicht nach geht es jetzt darum
das ergebnis 0 am schweizerischen
teilchenbeschleuniger hinter sich zu
lassen und im besten fall auch zu
überwinden eine völlig neue zeit in der
physik ist angebrochen wir sind gespannt
was da kommt ich habe hier bei klink
natürlich auf dem laufenden wenn ihr
kein videos zum thema und zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollte wird mir
hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst
nicht den genau auf die glocke hier geht
es weiter mit matrix sind wir nur
projektionen neue erkenntnisse zum
holografischen universum ein extrem
interessantes video also nicht verpacken
und draufklicken ansonsten bis dann
vielleicht dran